[MUSIC]
MARTY JOHNSON: It's only eight
miles between campus and here.
This is one of the wealthiest
counties in the country, and
this is one of the poorest urban
areas in the country.
[MUSIC]
MARIA FLORES-MILLS: I think
particularly for student
athletes, their focus is so much
about their sports and
their academics over the year
that this represents probably
a unique opportunity that
otherwise might not fit into
their schedules, but is another
way of them stepping
outside of the Princeton bubble,
actually seeing some
of their theories and class
work in action.
[MUSIC]
LUKE TAYLOR: Obviously, one
afternoon is just a drop in
the bucket.
But I think the major impact
that an afternoon like this
does is raise awareness among
student athletes at Princeton
in terms of how we can interact
with the community,
and what changes we can
make on a large scale.
[MUSIC]
JIM SIMON: Volunteer groups
allow us to have a lot of
diverse projects going on at one
time and be able to kind
of fill the demand for they're
getting things done
when we need it.
In this site here we're putting
in raised beds so we
can have some space for
production, but we're also
going to put in a small
greenhouse so we could make
use of the off-season
for growing.
But can also have this as
a place where we can do
demonstrations, maybe composting
workshops, have a
small greenhouse, do other
sorts of functions, do
environmental education
activities.
So a lot of multi-use space here
for urban agriculture.
[MUSIC]
BRANDON GLYCK: It's always a
great experience when you can
bring together all the athletes
on campus to do
something community-oriented
like this.
You don't always get to stay
in touch with a lot of
different athletes
because everybody
has different seasons.
Something like this is just a
great opportunity to bring
everybody together.
[MUSIC]
BOB CALLAHAN: First off, real
credit to the Princeton
Varsity Club to set up this
relationship in the first
place because it makes it
extra special as it is a
Princeton alumnus--
someone who has left school, was
an athlete here, but when
they left school decided to stay
in public service in a
way, and donating their
time and efforts
to improve the community.
It's nice to be able to connect
different generations
of Princeton alumni.
[MUSIC]